our most famous desert tortoise has yet
to make an appearance to
officially mark the return of
spring-like weather nate of course we're
talking about mojave max he is snoozing
the reptilian form of hibernation is
called brewmation
we're thinking he should be awake by now
our bianca holmen
live at the springs preserve where max's
house is hey bianca what's the update
hey sherry hey nate so yeah we finally
made it we made it to the springs
reserve all the way to mojave max's
presidential suite because it's 15 acres
and yeah he rents it out to a couple of
his friends there's five other tortoises
in there but
we know that mojave max has the ultimate
suite but uh yeah so there's so much
information out here with uh
his his area out here the preserved area
and we know that mojave max is one of a
desert tortoise and the longest
that he stayed hibernating was
until april 17th right and we're joined
here
by scott cambron uh he's a senior
biologist what's the earliest that uh
mojave max has come out uh he once came
out on valentine's day
oh and now is there something that
signifies that's going to happen or
that signifies when typically he would
come out and emerge
nothing specific there may be a lot of
factors such as
you know like temperature of the ground
temperature of the you know air
rain in this case maybe drought the lack
of rain things like that may all play a
part
all right so now how can folks see when
he comes out
i mean is there some type of sensor out
there tell us how can folks keep track
of him
we do have a camera a trail camera that
takes a photo based on movement so when
he comes out of the barrel they take
photos
and videos of him and then that ends up
on our
instagram or twitter or facebook page
now there is a way for
kids to get involved in this okay
through fifth graders what can they do
to get involved and learn more about
protecting
uh you know one of our most precious
animals of the desert yeah absolutely
so kindergarten through fifth grade kids
in clark county
public private or homeschooled can go
online to the mojavemax.com and they can
put in
a entry into our emergence contest so
and that person they pick a day an hour
and a
minute and the person that's the kid
that's closest um
wins uh adele chromebook uh pizza party
out here with his classmates
and a number of other prizes all right
so again so if you're
again probably our kids getting up ready
for school or about to head out and your
parents or grandparents
get your kid online get them involved
because again our desert tortoise is one
of our most protected
protected and precious animals of the
desert and also one last question
now if you see a tortoise crossing the
road do you pick them up do you let them
go do you try to protect them what
should you do if you see a desert
tortoise out there in
your yard or on the street um in a
normal situation in the desert you
should leave them alone not touch them
if it is in the road it's okay to grab
them and take them across the road in
the direction
they were traveling obviously getting
hit by a car is possibly the worst
case scenario so we don't want that to
happen outside of that though
enjoy them take photos but just leave
them wild all right perfect so again we
can keep up with mojavemax
on twitter instagram and of course the
spring preserve website
and hopefully i don't know maybe he'll
come out soon maybe he'll set a new
record
and come out april 18th i don't know but
i'm gonna go and make my wager online as
well back to you guys in the studio
it's not hard to keep up with mojave max
he doesn't move particularly fast in
fairness but
uh nate he's been in broomation as it's
called right brewmation
yes sir roommation now for for a long
time he's got a really good dream going
right now
when the weather gets cold i mean it's
similar to hibernation but the reptilian
form of hibernation is referred to as
brewmation so when it's get cold they
don't want to hang out
and even when it's super hot in the
summertime sherry
they'll spend a lot of their time in
their burrows yeah well because then
it's cool when it's so hot outside then
they go inside to cool down a little bit
i don't know i'm thinking alex and i
should apply for a desert tortoise
crossing guard jobs yes
can you see us out there on the road
going holding up traffic going all right
so give yourself a break we got
tortoises that are
moving through there are a couple of
signs out at uh red rock canyon that say
tortoise crossing and many areas
actually of uh southern nevada they
look for those yellow signs it's not
just deer it's also tortoises that cross
and
you got to give them the lane we just
make up a new job for ourselves
i'm all for it i don't know how much it
pays alex